today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video
okay let's start today with a story
about the failings of most Democrats in
the United States elected Democrats now
I'm still on the left the Democratic
Party is a center-left party I'm a
progressive this is a left-wing channel
we criticize the right all the time
today I'm going to criticize Democrats
on their response to the police protest
so let me set the stage for you
Republicans of course have completely
and utterly failed in their response to
the protest with the exception of for
example like Republican Senator Mitt
Romney who showed up and marched with
protesters and said black lives matter
which was mostly mostly just a political
show although I think it's an important
action and an important political show
but it's essentially a political show
Republicans have refused to admit that
there are systemic problems that need to
be dealt with
Kaleigh McEnaney did this yesterday
during her press briefing instead they
focus on phrases like sometimes there
will be instances of racism or bad
apples but meanwhile they often support
using even more force against protesters
who are protesting against police
brutality so the right is off the deep
end
I've also criticized some of the
activists on the Left who I believe are
taking the wrong approach for example
with defund or abolish the police I
already explained yesterday in detail
why I think that's the wrong approach
but today the point is I want to focus
on the failure the abject failure of the
Democratic Party leadership itself this
was a beautiful opportunity for the
Democratic Party to dramatically
distinguish itself from the Republican
Party I often talk about on many issues
Democrats and Republicans are very
different sometimes they're very similar
here was an opportunity for Democrats to
put together a blistering systemic
critique of how we got to where we are
with the protests as an outlet for much
of what is going wrong in our country if
you listen or watch listen to or watch
the clip from last Monday's show I broke
down how this is not just about police
brutality you need to look at this more
systemically what we're seeing is not
just about racism it's not just about
capitalism it's not just about health
care or culture it's all of these things
together and you need a wide-ranging
systemic critique to appreciate
everything that has gotten us to where
we are today and bias and policing is a
big part of that Democrats overall and
by this I mean elected Democrats
particularly House leadership and
Democrats in the Senate first really did
nothing eventually they said yeah we
support protests against police
brutality they participated in a bunch
of photo ops which mean meaningful in a
sense but doesn't really create a
systemic critique of what's going on and
it's great that Nancy Pelosi joined
protesters and talked to people it's
important that elizabeth warren joined a
protest it's great that Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden went
and spoke to protesters but this would
have been a perfect opportunity for a
big systemic critique that combines
everything from our economic system
problem with wages wealth inequality our
voting system so many other components
this was the opportunity to change the
narrative or create a narrative it could
have been like the Occupy Wall Street
moment where income inequality and
wealth inequality went mainstream you
had Republicans and Democrats
disagreeing about what should be done
about it
but Occupy Wall Street mainstreamed the
topic of wealth and income inequality
instead what we got from most Democrats
is this mild support of protesters
cautious of course never to support the
tactics that were used and very quick to
focus on how they don't agree with many
of the tactics which is fine but they're
they're missing the real big opportunity
in conjunction with some totally
farcical performative events like the
video that we're showing our radio our
the audience right now of House and
Senate Democrats kneeling for 8 minutes
and 46 seconds in honor of George Floyd
it is totally performative I'd be fine
with it if it came with a big systemic
critique and we've been sounding the
alarm for years about that sort of
necessary systemic critique because
there are so many different systems that
need to change now in addition to
Democrats not loving a valid systemic
criticism in terms of the systems that
got us where we are and need to be
changed there also
haven't been any real big comments from
establishment Democrats about the Civil
Liberties totalitarianism argument
Republicans have been going hard
demanding the military come in tougher
policing all of this stuff and Democrats
have sort of meekly opposed the tactic
said we're not in an agreement with the
military coming in but they've not
really gone after hey not only is
sending the military in wrong but
Republicans have spent years
criminalizing civil disobedience
criminalizing poverty criminalizing
journalism much like with the ag-gag
laws which now could be tied into the
protests as we see some journalists just
straight up beaten hit with shields and
batons and nightsticks
there's a much bigger story here that
the country is primed for right now
which Democrats could be taking
advantage of and they have not talking
about how so much about protesters
rights is inextricably linked to our
surveillance state warrantless
wiretapping NSA surveillance stingray
devices my point here is that there is
so much that is bigger than we like the
protesters and Trump shouldn't send in
the military and police brutality is bad
now why aren't Democrats doing it
there's a couple of perspectives one
explanation would be Democrats aren't
doing it because the Democratic Party is
very centrist and they don't really
believe in all that stuff that's true
but to some degree definitely it is not
true about all Democrat
there are many Democrats who are keeping
quiet for political expediency for
calculation that it's better for their
reelection if they don't talk about that
stuff in this context maybe they're
making the right calculation for their
reelection maybe they're not but this is
a huge missed opportunity and this is
one of the areas where the the scope of
debate has been narrowed dramatically
where there should be a big systemic
critique from Democrats here and instead
we are getting the military shouldn't
come in police brutality's a problem and
missing so much of what could really
change the dialogue in this country this
is a failure a moral failure by
Democrats whether it's a strategic
failure maybe it's not I mean maybe
they're making the right strategic
calculation in terms of their
re-elections but the moral failure is
impossible to ignore yesterday I told
you with all the normal disclaimers and
caveats that a new CNN poll has Donald
Trump down by a historic 14 points to
Joe Biden in national presidential
election polling 55 to 41 now this is
important not just because the 14 point
lead is unconscionable but it's also
important because a challenger hitting
50% so regularly five months before the
election is not very common Donald Trump
has had an absolutely wild tantrum in
response and I want to give you a look
at what he said and then we can fact
check it so Trump has been reportedly
going nuts on his campaign manager Brad
Parr scale
how could I be losing to Biden how could
these polls be true we talked yesterday
about this zoom call during which Corey
Lewandowski asked what exactly is our
message for re-election in November and
this all led to Donald Trump having a
tantrum tweeting quote CNN polls are as
fake as their reporting same numbers and
worse against crooked Hillary Dems would
destroy America so there are two
empirical claims being made there the
first is CNN's polling is bad Trump
calls it fake the second is that his
number
were even worse against Hillary in 2016
than they are today against Biden and
yet he's still managed to win in 2016 so
this is a great opportunity to just
examine empirical claims first is CNN a
good pollster or a bad pollster remember
the polling arms of a lot of these media
outlets are separate from the reporting
or broadcast arm so for example Fox News
polling is actually quite good despite
Fox News Channel being a right-wing hack
job
CNN polls are also well ranked they're
ranked B+ by 538 so cNN polling is quite
good
Trump's claim that cNN polling is bad is
incorrect second claim from Trump is
that he was polling even worse against
Hillary in 2016 and he's still won
that's simply not true if we go back and
look at June of 2016
meaning five months before the 2016
election just as right now were five
months out you can see if you're
watching that the with the exception of
one or two outliers Hillary Clinton was
more or less polling four points ahead
of Trump and reminder she did win the
popular vote against Trump by a couple
of points if you look at the polling of
Trump versus Hillary right before the
election you can see it was even closer
Hillary was ahead by three point two on
election day and she won by two point
one because remember these are popular
vote polls so Trump is wrong on both
counts
he's losing to Biden now by more than he
was losing to Hillary and CNN is a
pretty good pollster but it doesn't
really matter because this is all
narrative it's what can you tell your
supporters that will get them fired up
and fake News CNN is lying to you gets
his supporters fired up last thing Trump
then tweeted that he has hired a
pollster to debunk the CNN poll because
he was clearly so triggered by it
tweeting I have retained highly
respected pollster mcLaughlin and
associates to analyze today's CNN poll
and others which I felt were fake based
on the incredible enthusiasm we are
receiving read analysis for
yourself this is the same thing they and
others did when we defeat defeated
crooked Hillary in 2016 they are called
suppression polls and are out to dampen
enthusiasm despite three and a half
years of phoney witch hunts we are
winning and we will close it out on
November third again the letter Trump
posted with this analysis is all wrong
the McLaughlin memo wrongly states that
the CNN poll finding Biden up 14 is from
an all adults sample that's not true
CNN says very clearly in the methodology
it is a registered voter sample so even
the analysis of the poll that Trump paid
for is bogus so the final message this
election is nowhere near over this is
going to be a fight every voter should
assume from can win their state and you
should operate on that basis this is a
big gap so certainly Trump will number
one need a credible story as to here's
how I am fixing the economy here is how
I am dealing with the coronavirus well
because otherwise he's not going to be
able to turn it around so expect that
story to be told it'll probably be a
story of rehabilitation of the American
economy and number two Biden probably
needs to mess up at this point um in
order to squander the lead but both of
those things can happen we can't be
complacent we all have a role to play
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue chewed calm and use promo code
David you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay five dollars
shipping that's promo code David to get
your first shipment of blue to
completely free and I've put the link
right underneath this video one of the
police officers charged in the killing
of George Floyd is thomas lane thomas
lane has hired a lawyer named Earl Grey
and I can tell you this guy is not at
all lemony and mild like Earl Grey tea
he's actually quite the opposite and he
imploded on live television last night
he was interviewed by CNN's Chris Cuomo
and Earl Grey tried to suggest that if
bystanders were really so concerned with
how George Floyd was being manhandled by
police why didn't the bystanders jump in
to restrain the police he actually says
this and then he has no choice but to
back away from it when Chris Cuomo tells
him how bonkers it is what if all these
people say why why didn't my client
intercede well if the public is there
and there so enough more about this they
didn't intercede either in my clients
town where he can't really hold on
hold on counselor counselor hold on hold
on yes sir things once you're laying on
a man's legs you've got a fine view of
what's going on with that man the other
officer is literally a foot in front of
you on his neck - I understand that he
has a senior officer telling him what to
do but there's also a duty to intervene
anything good officer is doing something
that's dangerous to a civilian you have
a duty to intervene and he did not
intervene and the idea that the
civilians should have rushed in to a
policing situation in the inner city of
Minneapolis against four police officers
that have weapons and are kneeling on
the neck of a man don't you think that's
asking a little much of civilians and a
little too little of your client
absolutely I'm not I just brought that
up well what what you say is it went
away you know he's got his feet he was
holding his feet down mr. King was
officer King was next and then sha'ban
so obviously the suggestion of civilians
intervening against armed police is
ridiculous and Earl Grey realized it and
has to back off and say well I'm merely
bringing it up could this guy possibly
be a good lawyer his defense of his
client Officer Thomas Lane was to ask
why didn't civilians commit a crime
because if civilians actually go and try
to interfere with four armed officers in
the process of restraining and
subsequently killing George Floyd they
would have been arrested and likely
charged with interfering with law
enforcement now this is a good
opportunity to step back and give you a
sense of in general how the other
officers meaning the ones that were not
George Derek shavon might approach their
defenses the idea is to say there was a
power dynamic these guys like Thomas
Lane who is represented by attorney air
Earl Grey they were following orders
they weren't really in a position
because of seniority differences to
disagree even if they wanted to now
here's our friend Josh Campbell Campbell
former FBI agent CNN reporter friend of
the day
Pakman show asking Earl Gray about is
this the Pat is the power dynamic thing
what you were going with and Earl Gray
didn't like it at all take a look were
you kind of applying a power dynamic
between the scenes I'm sure right but is
here exactly is your claim that he was
following orders your client so Earl
Grey getting very upset there with a
pretty straightforward question from
josh campbell and then again another
example this is Earl Grey explaining my
client couldn't really do anything I
mean he couldn't restrain Derrick shavon
take a look be unreasonable for my
client to go up and drag in the front
and my guys back there with four days
shall we roll him over and he says no
won't wait for the ambulance twice and
then he says he's suffering from a
delirium I don't know what you're
supposed to do as a cop so that's the
gist of at least how Earl Gray will seek
to defend Thomas lanes actions in the
killing of George Floyd he was only on
the job a few days he didn't have the
power dynamics on his side he did
suggest rolling George Floyd over and he
couldn't really physically restrained
Eric Shaw in any way which is probably
accurate he physically restraining
Derrick shavon was not a likely path so
we've talked about many reforms by the
way but one that might benefit police is
to reorganize some of these a sort of
standards of the chain of seniority
there's a really interesting story that
Malcolm Gladwell tells in his book
outliers nearly 12 years ago at this
point about South Korean pilots which
explained that South Korean culture
precluded co-pilots from pointing out to
captain
hey I'm seeing something that doesn't
look right and under that cultural norm
South Korean aviation was not
particularly safe and so South Korean
Airlines retrained and said listen the
in the cockpit we have a different
protocol than in Korean culture and
first officers not only should be
allowed to but they should be encouraged
to point irregularities out to captain's
you won't be punished it's the right
thing to do and when they reorganize
that norm cultural norm in this case
South Korean aviation became
dramatically safer and much the same way
it is probably true that an officer on
duty for four days this is not a defense
of Thomas Lane but that one element is
true in police culture in the ranks it
would be seen as inappropriate or
unacceptable to question the tactics of
the senior officer in that particular
case that needs to be changed and that
is totally separate from how any of
these individual charges are ultimately
going to play out let's take a quick
break my interview with Neil Ferguson is
next make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
packager the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome Neil Ferguson to
the program today he's a historian and
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
whose new PBS series net world explores
the history and science of networks Neil
it's so great to have you on I
appreciate it thank you David great to
be with you so to start with as as a
historian or an historian as different
people love to argue about that's not
what I want to ask you about but as a
historian is the idea that things
eventually always sort of go back to
feeling the way we remember them feeling
is an inevitability or could we really
now be in in sort of a situation that
that marks a before-and-after that will
be important in the lives of people who
are living right now well yeah that's a
great question to ask an historian a
historian in London it sees an historian
because you don't say the age right it's
a good question to ask historian because
really we are in a position to look at
past pandemics and see the extent to
which they they changed the way people
lived and thought we forget I suspect
how frequent pandemics were in the past
and how exposed populations words are
contagious lethal diseases for example
in the 19th century cholera regularly
swept through major cities on both sides
of the Atlantic but
to Kili in Europe if you go back a
little further a smallpox was the
problem that people had to deal with in
the early American colonies and even
subsequently and if you want to go all
the way back to the Middle Ages you had
the dreadful problem of bubonic and
pneumonic plague which we call the Black
Death I think it's fair to say that
these great pandemics with really high
mortality did change things that is to
say people altered their behavior and
they they didn't interact and the the
way they had before for some time
subsequently if you read Daniel Defoe on
the great London plague of 1665 he talks
about the ways in which people had to
become less trusting of even people that
they they knew and there's an
interesting piece of research on the
long-lasting impacts of the nineteen
eighty nineteen influenza pandemic which
really seems to have affected trust in
those countries that were most badly
affected by the pandemic on the other
hand if you look at what we're going
through now it's not as bad a pandemic
as those it's not likely to kill as
large a share of the population as say
the Black Death which killed perhaps a
third of humanity and even the influenza
pandemic of 1918 nineteen killed between
two and three percent of people this is
not going to be by any means as
disastrous and so we probably won't be
as as strongly impacted actually I think
the economic measures we've taken in
particular the lockdowns will probably
have had a bigger impact than the
disease itself precisely because the
disease is so heavily concentrated on
certain groups it's so much more likely
to kill elderly people than the young
which makes it very different from other
pandemics so to cut a very long story
short I would say the best analogy might
actually be with a recent pandemic which
operated in different ways but killed a
great many people HIV AIDS HIV AIDS
changed the way people behaved sexually
and I think coded nineteen will change
the way people behave socially in
somewhat similar ways especially if
there's no vaccine in a reasonably short
timeframe and that's a big and crucial
variable if there is a vaccine if it's
rapidly discovered if it works really
well and it's generally available this
time next year then I'm not sure that
our behavior will radically change over
the long term but if that vaccine
doesn't turn up then I think you can see
big changes in social behavior somewhat
similar to the changes in sexual
behavior that came after hiv/aids
so you mentioned trust and I'm
interested in hearing a little bit about
you know when we think about the the
affective networks and networks in which
we our participants are involved in so
to speak what is your sense of the
factors that most are influencing the
individual decisions people are making
about do I go out and protest or not
against the lockdowns or against police
brutality do I wear a mask or don't I
wear a mask etc is it about who is in
your personal network is it about the
news you consume is it about what the
CDC says if you are part of a certain
network but not part of another what's
your sense of that that's a great
question David the way I think about
this is that there are really two
pandemics going on concurrently one is
the biological pandemic where a new
coronavirus are scoff to spreads around
the world very rapidly and creates all
kinds of dislocations as well as excess
mortality but there's this other
pandemic of information disinformation
misinformation that is going on online
and in some ways some of that contagion
is even more rapid in its spread and
extensive in its spread are actually
more likely to encounter viral nonsense
about covert 19 then covered 19 itself
because the second pandemic spreads much
more rapidly and you can catch a wrong
idea from the Internet which which you
can't do with the virus it requires you
to be in the same physical space as a
carrier so I think the second pandemic
is really interesting because it makes a
huge difference
to your experience and your assessment
of risk how you are networks to the rest
of the world if you are the kind of
person who gets information from
mainstream media who perhaps is quite
selective in what you read
perhaps you dip into quality newspapers
in more than one country and carefully
filter outs
click Bayes then you'll form the view as
I would say I have that this pandemic
ain't over and if you are particularly
in an older age group you should not be
rushing into crowded situations even if
they're outdoors but if you're somebody
who gets information from a very
different set of sources perhaps you're
very exposed to the kind of influences
on the far left or the far right who are
very likely to circulate misinformation
and disinformation you might form the
conclusion either that this thing is
over and we should just be getting right
back to normal which is certainly a
widespread view on in some quarters or
you might think well it's still an issue
but I should be much more outraged about
social justice questions and therefore I
should protest because somehow or other
the virus is going to give me a break if
I'm doing something virtuous so it
depends very heavily where you are in a
world where information is no longer
mainly distributed by terrestrial
television stations as it was say back
in the 60s a world in which information
is channeled through very complex
networks in which influences some of
whom you may never even have heard of
have enormous numbers of followers and
can very quickly persuade them of
something that is in fact quite quite
untrue about the nature of the virus so
in thinking about some of these
different ideas and conclusions that
people may integrate into their beliefs
again depending on the networks in which
they participate depending on the media
that they consume I want to try to link
this back to something I discussed with
Jonathan hight when he was on the
program which related to sometimes it
seems as though people may
vote our act against their own personal
interests and one of the ideas that
Jonathan high and others have introduced
is that while it that may be true what
may matter to a greater degree is how
much their actions fit into the
interests that whatever orthodoxy or
group they subscribe to has determined
is what's good for them a good example
would be the tea party in the US and
2010 where you had individuals seemingly
supporting a policy that would not be
particularly good for them because they
weren't rich but it was still I don't
know that I want to use their rationale
but we could understand the behavior
better if we understood how group
motivations played a role does that
apply to who is doing the protesting
against lockdowns versus who is in who
is wearing a mask
versus who isn't this sort of group
analysis rather than individual well
people have been thinking about these
questions for a long time Antonio
Gramsci came up with the notion of false
consciousness when he was trying to
explain the failure of the proletariat
to line up in support of Marxism as an
ideology and of course it was a
recurrent feature of European and
American history in the 19th and 20th
centuries that working-class people
stubbornly refused to support socialists
parties so this is quite an old problem
in social science especially for the
United States where socialism was a sort
of non-event until relatively recently
and attracted very little support I
think if you if you're asking do people
act against their own individual
self-interest because of an ideology or
because of a sense of a wider community
the answer is yes they do again and
again and again and that's partly
because of the appeals that can be made
whether it's to your class identity or
your racial identity or your ethnic
identity these appeals are quite potent
and by contrast it's always a little
harder than it
looks to establish exactly what your own
self-interest is in economics for many
years we tried to imagine a rational
calculating machine Homo economicus
whose goal was just to maximize utility
but as historians we struggled to find
these people they're really rather
unusual and and indeed not very popular
when they do turn up people like that
exist but you tend to find them running
hedge funds rather than being your
everyman so every man is quite inclined
to be swayed by collective consciousness
by ideas of group loyalty when it comes
down to behavior in the pandemic I think
there are there are two distinct forms
of I'll call it irrational behavior
there's the form that says even although
the number of cases and hospitalizations
is going are going up in my state I'm
still going to go back to work and I'm
gonna go back to the stores and I'm not
gonna wear a mask because the bells of
he'll go tingling the for you but not
for me in other words people essentially
don't think they personally are going to
get the virus now that may be because
they're young and they say to themselves
well I've read that it really only kills
the elderly and therefore my risk is
pretty low but what's odd is that we
find quite a lot of older people who say
in surveys that they're in favor of
rapid reopening even before the
pandemics under control in in their area
on the side of people who recently
protested it might be said that outdoors
it's much harder to catch covered 19
than indoors and the most protests are
outdoors therefore there's not much risk
but when you look at the crowds they're
pretty densely packed and the shouting
and we know from the literature that the
the key to transmission of of SARS cough
to is it's not just talking in a normal
way it's shouting and singing that
really along with coughing and sneezing
that propels the virus from a carrier to
others so there's some risk involved in
going to these protests most of the
protesters are relatively young but I
saw Mitt Romney out in the streets
yesterday wearing a mask prudently but
it's
hard to tell I've just looked at many
shots and video clips I wouldn't say a
majority of protesting people have been
wearing masks and I wouldn't say that
they're all as it were young enough not
to worry in any case even if you are
young enough not to be too worried about
SARS cough to you you should be worrying
about the older people that you're going
to meet subsequent to your protest had a
conversation my daughter about this last
night she's distinctly to the left of me
politically but she had wisely resisted
peer group pressure to go on a march in
London on the ground that she would soon
be seeing her mother and grandmother who
are in the vulnerable age group and so
that that seemed like a pretty good
example of somebody coming to a good
decision even under peer group pressure
and peer group pressures a huge part of
what's going on here people may suspect
they're doing something that's not
prudent but they kind of give in to the
peer group pressure I was glad what my
daughter resisted that when it comes to
beliefs about blame and responsibility
around the virus there's definitely some
interesting network effects going on I
was interested to see in your recent
interview with Andy serwer I'll let you
sort of characterize in detail your
position but at least generally speaking
you seem to probably assign less
responsibility to the federal government
and Trump's actions than I would
although I do believe that there have
been unfair accusations also cast at the
federal government which were either
beyond anyone's control or more relevant
to a mayor or a governor for example
what do you think are the unfair
criticisms that are or blame that is
being placed on the president maybe we
can start there well I think it's worth
saying right away that the primary
responsibility for this pandemic lies
with the Chinese government and also the
provincial authorities in Hebei province
who really criminally failed to deal
with the problem and were slow to admit
the extent at which human to human
transmission was happening a granade
imposing travel bans until it was really
much too
so that's part one part two of the
answer is that the media obsession with
President Trump which he of course
encourages lead I think to a tendency to
overemphasize the president's role in
reality in a crisis of this sort the
agencies that really matter are those
responsible for pandemic preparedness
and that is a part of the Department of
Health and Human Services not just CDC
which has got a lot of the stake but we
have an undersecretary or I think an
assistant secretary to be exact at DHHS
whose job this is and who had written
and spoken a good deal on the subject in
fact if you delve into it the federal
bureaucracy had generated any number of
reports on pandemic preparedness and
PowerPoint decks with multiple slides
and indeed on paper the United States
was well prepared for a situation like
this it was just that when it actually
happened back in January and right
through February and into March that the
agencies responsible the people whose
job this was did terribly and we can say
that I think fairly because we can see
where it was done much better in
countries where public health
bureaucracies were quick to respond like
in for example Taiwan or South Korea or
Germany for that matter you don't just
need to look at Asian countries so the
u.s. in common with I'd say also the
United Kingdom did really badly dealing
with a problem they were supposed to be
ready for making it all about Trump I
think is a mistake which misunderstands
the nature of government it is not that
the president sits there in the White
House with his phone ready to tweet
deciding on everything that's just not
the way it works the federal government
is a hugely complex thing with multiple
agencies more than 60 in total and there
is an agency who has this job and they
failed and not nearly enough has been
written about that in my view this is
not to say Trump did great he did quite
badly his decision-making was erratic he
had some good instincts like we have to
do something about people coming in from
China but it came much too late to make
any difference at all at the end of
January
and I think instinctively Trump felt
that lockdowns were a mistake which I
think was right - because it was an
incredibly blunt instrument to deal with
the contagion and not necessary if in
fact you've done the right things early
on so you know you you can't say it's
all his fault I think that's a great
mistake but nor can you say he's done a
great job I mean in the end the the buck
stops with the president the United
States as Harry Truman said long ago and
so one can't say well it was all the
faults of dhhs not the president's fault
he's the president ultimately the buck
stops with him there's no question that
the United States has handled this
pandemic very much worse than it should
have very much worse than other
comparable countries and that is why we
have the highest death toll and may well
end up with a very high excess mortality
rate by the end of the year so maybe
we're not actually that far I mean in
hearing you lay it out it seems like
some of this is about the president as
the per you know HHS run by Alex a czar
who early on thought it was a good idea
to port a former Labradoodle dealer in
charge of the day-to-day okay that was a
bad decision
he is Trump's pick to run HHS so a lot
of this seems to be the semantics of
Trump's delegation versus Trump's
actions I mean I think the biggest
critique certainly would be when you
look at South Korea and the u.s. finding
our first cases within hours of each
other
South Korea rapid test development fever
clinics isolation contact tracing that
happened six weeks later or it started
to happen in a serious way six weeks
later the testing capacity was a joke
I do think you know you can't blame
Trump for a hundred thousand one hundred
and ten thousand deaths of course there
was probably a period there I would say
around you know aggressively March tenth
less aggressively March twenty-fifth
where the requests for a coordinated
50-state stay at home that would be long
over by now had it been done from the
start and we wouldn't have what we now
have rolling opening and closing Florida
and Texas spiking while fortunately here
in Massachusetts were doing well that
certainly was a loss
the opportunity for Trump and I would
even say it was a lost opportunity from
a campaign standpoint I think that he
has now suffered greatly because he
didn't do some of these things that may
have been economically unpopular at
first but would likely have him with a
much higher than 38 percent approval
today I wonder if you agree it's
difficult on that I mean my sense is
that by mid March it was it was too late
and that blanket shelter and place
orders would not really have had a huge
impact by that stage other than in fact
to magnify the economic shock let me
reiterate the key decision points were
in January as soon as it became clear
there was a problem yes and right into
February when President Trump and many
others in the administration were
downplaying the threat and not only
President Trump
remember at the end of January when
Trump called for a travel ban on Chinese
passengers coming into the US he was
widely criticized in the liberal media
accused essentially of racism and there
were multiple articles at that time in
liberal circles saying it's just the flu
in fact you should worry much more about
the flu and for me as somebody who was
writing no this really isn't the flu
this is very much more serious it was
maddening to see such ill-informed
rubbish being published so widely there
was a bipartisan failure to recognize
the scale of the threat that went on
right into February I can remember being
in Washington in mid-february trying to
convince people in the administration
this thing is real you have got to do
something and you particularly have to
tell the president to stop saying there
is no threat to the United States it's
just going to disappear so it was it was
then that I think the really disastrous
mistakes were made by mid-march they had
been insouciant for so long that they
were actually thrown into panic by
another Neil Ferguson it's worth
clarifying that I'm not him any il
Ferguson the epidemiologist at Imperial
College London who published a report on
March 16 saying that if you didn't have
lockdowns 2.2 million people were going
to die in the United States and half a
million in the UK and both the London
and Washington governments flipped when
they saw
this as did many people who saw the
report or read about it and we went from
total insouciance to total panic this
was really the worst of both worlds
because we had dithered around when we
should have been taking early action and
then we did a bunch of extremely blunt
instrument measures like shelter and
place orders and economic lock downs
that it doesn't seem to me have
radically changed the spread or slowed
the spread of the virus social
distancing was something that mattered a
lot when people adopted that even not at
the order of the state it had a big
impact the lock downs have clearly done
much more economic harm than Public
Health good so as I said we've ended up
with this kind of worst of both worlds
and it's not over and for me the
depressing thing is seeing people
behaving all over the country as if it
is over in in defiance of the reality
that if you just look at numbers of
confirmed cases there are second waves
already in about a dozen states it's
already happening and so let me ask ya
so the last thing I wanted to touch on
was for a while I've been fearing that
there was going to be a point at which
it's going to be sort of unclear what
each person should be doing here in
Massachusetts today outdoor dining gets
to open and then this is phase 2a and
then we're going to get to phase 2b
where something else can happen and you
know I don't know I'm in my mid-30s I'm
probably fine to go and sit outside at a
restaurant but should I do it and is it
if you need a mask is this is that a
signal that I shouldn't be doing it or
that what do you make of this phase now
that could last really it could last
until there's a vaccine I don't know how
long it's going to last where there's
going to be a lot of needing to sort of
figure out for oneself what is the
appropriate behavior yes I think you're
right to feel confused and uncertain
because mixed policy signals at the
national and state level have created
exactly that sense of confusion all over
the country and this goes back to what
we were talking about earlier when
people are uncertain but get their
information from let's say more
sensationalistic sources
then they will take action that is in
fact not going to help and might even
harm them hydroxychloroquine for example
is an example of something that was
touted as a remedy not just by the
president but by many other people but
the only really good scientific research
on this suggests that it has no real
prophylactic effect and it's quite
harmful if you are suffering seriously
from covert 19 so as people try to work
out what to do their battling against a
combination of poor quality public
information from the government I mean I
think our public health bureaucracy has
failed at the communications level by
the way really interesting piece on this
subject in the New York Times just about
a week ago going through what exactly
went wrong at CDC it's well worth
reading unlike many things in the New
York Times and and it actually shows a
classic pathology of a burek
bureaucratic organization very
hierarchical very slow-moving and easily
bullied by the White House when the
going got tough it is a very very stark
illustration of a problem that the great
physicist Richard Feynman identified
long ago in the case of the Challenger
Space Shuttle disaster
it's the mid-level bureaucracy that's
often the problem in disasters like this
so we as individuals are getting poor
information from the public authorities
and even worse information from the
internet what are we going to do well we
have to make sure that we read carefully
what is out there that is reputable
that is to say has some solid basis in
scientific research and on that basis my
advice to you is you probably fine to go
and eat outside in Massachusetts on a
nice day you should wear a mask and you
should really keep your distance from
from other people as far as you can just
to be on the safe side because
Massachusetts is a state where there are
still quite a high level of cases of
code 19 being diagnosed that everyday
would I advise you to go into a crowded
office or to take a credit form of
public transport no I'd say avoid those
things avoid any crowded indoor space
especially if people are shouting
or singing so forget choir practice and
if somebody says let's serve a reopening
party come on round to my place a
politely decline because those are very
likely that super spreader events that
we're gonna get in the coming weeks and
months that will keep this pandemic
going in the United States for much
longer than was necessary seems
eminently reasonable I would say we've
been speaking with Neil Ferguson he is
an historian and the new PBS series net
world explores the history and science
of networks Neil really appreciate your
time today
thanks David it's been a pleasure and
enjoy that enjoy that dinner through
Moscow that's the problem that's the
that's the logistical issue I will
figure it out though thank you the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay this is not the most important
story of the day but it is one of those
if they're lying about this what else
are they lying about types of stories
not this past Friday but the one before
was reported that Donald Trump was
brought down to the bunker below the
White House for his safety and this is
it's not actually something to laugh at
these are decisions
Secret Service makes about the safety of
the president but Donald Trump kept
tweeting and acting like a big man and
some started pointing out you know big
tough Trump won't go near the protesters
and instead tweets from the safety of
his basement bunker so Trump was
triggered by this he came out and he
denied that he went to the bunker for
safety reasons he said oh I did I
decided I wanted to go down and inspect
the bunker on that particular day this
was what he told Fox & Friends a few
days after the incident they don't
Leland Vera twittered reporting no
problem we've got dark a huge problem he
was attacked and then the reports were
there was so worried they brought you
downstairs and the White House to a
bunker what could you tell me Sunday
night Sunday night was like for you and
your family well it was a false report I
was at then I went down during the day
and I was there for a tiny little short
period of time it was much more for an
inspection there was no problem during
the day the problem I saw Leland got
whacked pretty good but that was during
the night and this problem these
problems are during the night that
during the day and I go down I've gone
down two or three times all for
inspection and you go there some day you
may need it but you go there and I went
down I looked at it it was during the
day it was not a problem and I read
about it like a big thing there was
never a problem we never had a problem
nobody ever came close to giving us a
problem the Secret Service it does an
unbelievable job of maintaining control
in the White House right Trump claiming
that he regularly inspects the bunker
for no other reasons then I guess to
make sure that it's up to his
construction standards so this was
obviously not true when he said it but
now hilariously Donald Trump's own
attorney General William Barr said no
Secret Service recommended
go down to the bunker this is from
yesterday it was a Fox News interview
with Bret bear and bar doesn't even
pretend he just admits to the entire
thing and the context was bar defending
just how dangerous it was last Monday
when protesters had to be cleared with
gas and and horses and bar saying you
know it was so crazy that we had to have
that the Secret Service recommend that
Trump go down to the bunker a lot of
talk about Monday kind of reliving the
moment there in Lafayette Park if you
had to do Monday over again would you do
something different based on what I know
now on Monday we were reacting to three
days of extremely violent demonstrations
right across from the White House a lot
of injuries to police officers arson the
things were so bad that the Secret
Service recommended the president go
down to the bunker we can't have that in
our country oh okay so Secret Service
did recommend Trump go to the bunker
because Trump said he was inspecting it
on what just happens to be the same day
that Secret Service recommended that he
go go down there so I don't want to beat
a dead horse
we all knew Trump was obviously lying
when he said he was inspecting the
bunker but the reminder is if he lied
about this what else is he willing to
lie about and the answer is everything
he's willing to lie about everything now
just to warn you at some point the
defense is going to come out and they
are going to say bar never said Trump
went to the bunker because of the Secret
Service bar said the Secret Service
recommended Trump go to the bunker and
Trump didn't except to inspect the
bunker on the same day not because
Secret Service recommended it it's nuts
and it's just you know it's one little
example of this by the way I didn't get
to this but speaking of lying ten days
ago Trump mentioned that he spoke to the
Indian Prime Minister and the Indian
prime minister said that he was not in a
good mood about what was going on with
China
that conversation never happened so just
again the constant lies Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi has not spoken
with Donald Trump about the South Asian
Nations military standoff with China but
Donald Trump claimed that a conversation
took place about that and Modi was in a
really bad mood like it just didn't
happen that conversation didn't happen
so he's lying about the bunker he's
lying about conversations he's lying
about everything that's the real take
away don't forget it okay Donald Trump's
latest non mask visit to a PPE factory
has led to an entire day's production of
medical swabs being thrown in the trash
destroyed this was on a trip to Maine
that Trump did a few days ago he went to
Bangor Maine Guilford Maine maybe one
other spot the company he visited is
called Puritan medical products and
among other things they make sterile
cotton swabs or Schwab's as Trump once
referred to them these are sterile
meaning workers wear lab coats hair nets
plastic booties over their shoes all of
that stuff in walks Trump with no masks
walks around talks to people we're
showing our audience that's watching TV
footage of Trump walking around getting
closer to everybody than the recommended
six feet and this of course raised a
bunch of questions hey this is supposed
to be a sterile environment and the
marketing manager had to admit that
indeed swabs produced during this time
meaning when Trump was there will be
discarded in their defense or or I guess
in Trump's defense they were only
planning a limited production run that
day in light I guess of Trump's presence
there Puritan is one of only two
factories in the entire country that
makes these swabs there are still
shortages in some areas even in Maine
one third of nursing homes were out of
swabs last month
60% of Maine nursing homes had seven or
fewer individual swabs on hand so an
entire day's production of swabs in the
trash because Donald Trump who had to
walk around with that doofus see
expression on his face uncovered by a
mask so in the end maybe the real
tragedy is not they throughout all of
that day swabs maybe the real tragedy is
that while facing swab shortages the
entire factory mostly shut down because
Trump was coming to visit and they
produced very little to begin with
instead of having a full and real
production day of swabs to get swabs to
people who need them but once again I
have to ask why did the factory allow
Trump to go in without a mask and
without booties on his shoes I get it
he's the president but at some point
this has to stop right like I would love
to see a company just fully insist it
doesn't matter if it's the president
you're not coming in without a mask
period no exception end of story don't
try to bully us just either wear the
mask or go somewhere else but at the
same time I do get it because there's
perceived prestige associated with a
sitting president coming to tour your
facility in rural Maine people will let
him do whatever he wants which is the
story of his life and they did here I
mean remember grab him by the
you-know-what that's a story about Trump
gets whatever he wants Trump not wearing
masks when he goes to places even when
the production floor is supposedly
sterile that's another example of Trump
gets whatever he wants that's the story
of his life and maybe someday a factory
or some business or someone will say
it's not happening my friend it is not
happening we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today
we are going to talk about how the
average American views police after the
last ten days of protests how is public
opinion about police shifted in the last
10 days number two South Korea and North
Korea are no longer talking and
geopolitics experts are worried about
what this might a signal for the future
and lastly Donald Trump is planning to
re-establish those massive campaign
rallies in the next two weeks
potentially making them super spreader
events of coronavirus we will talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com and
of course remember if
prefer to consume the show in long-form
audio format instead of clips on YouTube
if that's where you're watching right
now we have a free daily audio podcast
this the free audio podcast it is on
iTunes it's on Google podcasts it's on
Spotify it's on Pandora it's on stitcher
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
you can find the david pakman show
podcast get it but then become a member
and we'll see you on the bonus show
momentarily
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video